- [Lisa] Think of being in
a freezer and then somebody
puts your face directly into
a big pile of wet ice cubes.
(playful music)
That's what it feels like.
- [Narrator] I'm speaking to Lisa Kelly.
She's a scuba diver
with National Geographic,
and she leads expeditions in
Antarctica and the Arctic.
(water splashes)
Temperatures in arctic
waters typically range
between 25 and 35 degrees Fahrenheit.
Because the waters are so cold,
divers have to use special gear.
This includes the use of a dry suit.
These suits actually keep divers dry
when they're underwater.
- [Lisa] I like to call
it a self-induced state
of hypothermia, really,
because even though you're dry,
you're still going to get cold.
And that is such a shock
on peoples' system.
Unfortunately there have been deaths due
to cardiac incidents because of that.
- [Narrator] Aside from the
cold, there are other things
that divers need to be on the lookout for.
(walrus roar)
- [Lisa] Walrus and to a
certain extent, polar bears.
(bear roar)
Animals like killer
whales reverberate sound,
we call it pinging, it sounds
like a gunshot under water.
It can go right through you.
(atmospheric music)
- [Narrator] But Lisa
Kelly says that diving
in the Antarctic and the Arctic
is an unparalleled experience.
And it starts on the boat.
- [Lisa] That initial
feeling when you fall back
in the water, it's just
the sound of you breathing
through your regulator.
It suddenly becomes your own little world.
All of a sudden, all these amazing colors
start to pop out.
It really is a whole other universe.
And in Antarctica, you're
there in a place where possibly
nobody has ever dived before.